How old is SCP-106 really? Is this ferocious
fogie really as ancient as you think?
Depends on who you think he is.
If you think he’s actually Dr. Robert
Scranton, who disappeared into SCP-3001
as an adult back in the year 2000, he’s
likely between 60 and 80 years old.
If you believe he’s actually Corporal
Lawrence, who was an adult likely in
his thirties during World War One, he’d
currently be well over a century old.
And if you’re really spicy, and believe he’s a
holdover from a whole species of SCP-106s who
went into hibernation when his species went
extinct, he’s likely been alive for anywhere
between 40,000 to 130,000 years. Now that’s a
whole lot of birthday candles to try and blow out!
No wishes granted for this guy this year.
My god, he really is an Old Man...